good evening what's up baby boy
how has your night gone so far not too
bad man how's your night going
pretty good pretty good um well
until you ruin it of course well yeah it
always goes well until our lessons you
know
it's yeah i mean it comes with the
territory though exactly
exactly so um
i'll start with giving you sort of the
lay of the land congratulations by the
way i'm hitting
and hitting uh 1000. very good thank you
you know despite my critical nature
um i have to give credit where it's too
that is a big milestone
thank you ben yeah we worked hard for
this we did
and now the sky's the limit i mean two
thousand that's that's the next number
of the horizon
i think yeah man i think it's like a
month away
ah i mean that's absolute higher end i
think more like a week or two weeks
i mean hopefully what's another thousand
points
um child score exactly and then 3 000
and
then you're at mount olympus so i was
thinking
uh of starting by kind of giving you
again the lay of the land what i think
your
your top weaknesses are what our
priorities are going forward
um for let's say the next couple of
weeks and if you solve
and identify sort of four distinct
issues
and they're obviously interconnected you
know by solving one you get better at
another
but if you solve all four of them i
think that you hit
13 1400 or so okay cool
now obviously problem number one is is
the speed which
obviously you don't need me to tell you
that but but i think that we're gonna
you're gonna get better at that by
getting better at other things you're
gonna get more confident at making
different types of moves and hopefully
the result of that is that you don't
hesitate as much in certain types of
positions so what are those moves
i think that someone told me you
mentioned earlier when you were playing
alexandra
um that you struggle with kind of
maintenance moves that's that are
neither
distinctly attacking nor distinctly
defending it's just like moves that
improve your position
yep i definitely don't recognize when a
maintenance move is
necessary or when it's optimal and
that's i think
exactly right i think that part of the
reason for your hesitation you start
looking for that knockout blow
and if that knockout blow isn't there
you can spend 10 minutes looking for
something that's not there and then you
have no idea what to do
so we're gonna work on that today
partially i mean there's a lot of things
we could work on so
we need to pick and choose um the second
well i guess the third thing
is openings actually so you know you
play e4 knight f3 bishop c4
and with black you kind of do the same
thing but i think that the time has come
for you to learn actual real stuff
that you know is likely to pose
significant problems for your opponent
right out of the gate
you know whereas i think right now your
repertoire is built around kind of
getting out of the opening getting a
reasonable position
i think that you can start actually
getting a little bit more ambitious
and learning slightly new stuff is also
going to expose you
to different types of positions and all
of that is kind of going to come
together but
the doubt well quote-unquote downside is
it's a very difficult process you know
there's a lot of growing pains
associated with
playing something that you've never
really played before it can be
frustrating
but i don't want to force that upon you
if you feel like you're not ready to
potentially take that on in the
immediate future
no i'm fine to learn some some new
openings i tried to karo khan today
against
alexandra it didn't uh didn't go very
well but
based on what i've seen in our games i
thought i kinda could start it
[Music]
is an interesting choice actually not
playing one e5 uh we could also learn
one e5
one e5 properly and i was thinking of
starting with white
and teaching you um well it's it's funny
me saying
i'm teaching you this but it's the
scotch the four night scotch
the last time you faced the sky you
remember what happened but don't shoot
the messenger the opening itself
is actually fantastic and i think it'll
teach you a lot about
how to play the types of positions that
right now
you know constitute gaps in your
understanding okay
you know i've done i've put some thought
into this i've consulted some
some of my chess coach friends um who
are even more experienced than i am and
that's
the conclusion that we've reached and
again at any moment if you feel like
yeah this is [ __ ]
you you say the words and and we change
immediately you know there's no
there's nothing to lose essentially well
i'm
assuming it's not going to be like dog
[ __ ] i don't think you're going to train
me
terribly as a joke or at least i hope
not absolutely i would never do such a
thing no no
never um and so there's openings
there's maintenance moves which i think
are sort of the urgent priority
and then finally other than speed
there's technique that i think still
you need some work converting material
advantages and getting comfortable
winning winning positions so those four
things i think are the top priorities
now today
we can do a mix of all four we can do
all of them obviously we can't get to
everything
and do it deeply do you have a
preference um in terms of
obviously we could analyze some of the
games that you played against alexander
if you feel like they're
um instructive and might give us a key
to to improvement
i'm really fine with whatever you think
is going to be the most effective use of
our time
because you'd know better than i would
what's gonna be easier what's gonna take
longer
okay okay so i think that we should
perhaps start with with one warm-up game
just one just to get you kind of into
the zone
and then we'll jump right into some
maintenance move training
and i think that's going to be both fun
and potentially instructive and maybe
we'll finish off by
starting out um some opening training
okay that works for me so just hop in
the pool then fantastic
putting your 1 000 rating at risk but
yeah you're gonna be
it's about time it's about time i've
been sitting on this glory for
like a week now yeah it's that feeling
of
of getting a new tv or a new car it's
it's past it's like when i became a gm
you know i thought
my life is gonna be fulfilled and the
next morning i still i wake up and i
still have to pee so
like all right damn i'm sorry to hear
that
yeah i mean i thought that my faculties
my necessary faculties would have
somehow been shut off but they weren't
all right so you stumped him with a
berlin variation
castles do i want this free pawn
that is the theoretical continuation um
but it's yeah so what i was looking at
yeah what i was looking at instead was
knight to d4 attack bishop
or trade knight and get my pawn at d4 i
don't know which is better
that's a pretty ambitious continuation i
kind of like the the edge that that
brings i think it's a little dubious but
you can go ahead and give that a shot
yeah that's the first thing i looked at
i just kind of like that idea i know
he's just gonna take with the night but
i also like having the pawn there
right and and this these next couple
weeks are gonna be an age of
experimentation for you you're gonna try
out new ideas that
at first feel really weird because
you're maybe not comfortable with them
you see and he
he gives you a very important piece that
you can now take
yeah so do i uh i guess the question is
do i just want the bishop then instead
of the knight
yeah definitely that bishop is one of
his most important pieces and he brings
his knight to a very awkward
square and i still get a pawn out of it
you could take that pawn but remember
your pawn on e5 is hanging and you're
not developed so
if i were you i would prioritize
defending that e5 pawn and then
developing asap
so developing with the pawn pushing that
to d6 yeah
freeing up the bishop i think that's the
most solid choice it's not that taking
the pawn would have been bad but
it would have taken a lot of precision
to handle the complications there
he's playing well so i kind of like the
idea of just bringing bishop to d7
something not imposing threatening
knight get the night off okay and then
perfectly solid choice and remember one
thing i want you to
bear in mind you don't always have to
bring your bishops out to g4 and b4
sometimes just bringing your bishop out
to d7 and e7 is solid but
look at the central tension is he is he
threatening anything
yeah so right now i take he'd take with
knight i can't take back
i don't think he's gonna develop his
queen over his knight wouldn't make much
sense
uh he takes i take which frees up the d
file
um but he's threatening your pawn on e5
you see that right
yeah so you need to deal with that
tension
okay so do it do i just take then yeah
and look up
again not all trades are going to be
winning for you some of them are just
maintenance trades
just to otherwise you lose upon it's
either trade upon or lose upon
okay that makes sense then i guess
recognizing that's going to be another
thing i need to work on
oh yeah we'll you know i'll give you a
workout shortly
on all of that next move i was looking
at was
pushing c5 pawn get the queen out and
then go back to development
castle on short side here but does
playing c5 create any pawn weaknesses in
your position does it weaken any pawns
that he might potentially attack
makes that v7 pawn weaker b7 i would say
that d6 spawn
that d6 bomb loses the protection of its
of its neighboring pawn on c7
i can't protect it with a pawn only my
bishop right that queen on d4 it's not
doing that much it's just sitting there
in the center it's being annoying but
you don't have to attend to it just yet
i would just keep developing
okay so then just bringing the bishop
out to e7 and just castling
yep exactly which is
and this type of chess is also something
that you need to learn to play you know
your position doesn't look imposing
but it's solid you have no weaknesses
you have the two bishops
and he does not have a clear plan
of i don't know crashing through doing
anything specific so
we'll see how he handles this yeah this
bishop play doesn't really do much since
it's not going to pin knight to queen or
anything so i still just want to castle
here yep
exactly he is playing
very well so far i mean he's displaying
knowledge of
you know good opening development but
your position is is extremely solid
yup he's continuing to play well
but not to worry
so this is one of those situations where
you'd want to make a maintenance move
okay is there any piece that
you could just bring into the game that
right now isn't doing anything
yeah i still have that rook hanging on
a8 uh as for the best square for that i
don't really know but i could also move
my rook to uh
here you go bingo bingo that's exactly
right okay there are pieces that
you know i would love for that a rook to
appear on g4 guess what i'd like for a
filet mignon steak from ruth and chris
to appear on my desk i can't [ __ ]
have that right now
is ruth and chris a friend of yours or
is that like a chain that's a steak
house
from it's a chain i don't even know why
i've never been there i i don't know why
i said that as opposed to like outback
are you i don't know if you're an
outback guy i've had outback i used to
like it when i was a kid but not so much
anymore
so he is playing like a gm right now but
so are you so again same question is
there any piece that perhaps a little
bit passive you could make it a little
bit more active perhaps bring it out
onto a slightly more open diagonal
yeah i was looking at moving one of
these bishops out here to see
bingo that's exactly the move that i had
in mind pressure that pun right
you're not threatening to take it
immediately but you're simply improving
the position of your bishop
and he pushes e5 now
okay so
you need to attend to the central
tension can you do what is the first
thing that comes to your mind
well taking the pawn he'll likely
just he'll either take it back with the
knight
or he'll just go in with a queen and
just trade queens but
well he wouldn't do that right because
that's not a great position for him
right so you've got to do what you got
to do though like he
the decision is his whether he wants an
end game but in either case you're going
to have a fine position you have the two
bishops
yeah so i just have to take the pawn
yeah i don't see much of an alternative
now if he if you'll play the move queen
to c4 i'll get a little suspicious okay
he takes to the knight
now this is the situation which you
normally struggle with
where the correct move is something you
really don't like to do but you have to
which is what
play a retreating move well that's it
there's a second thing you don't like to
do which is which is what else
trading right great i feel like
subconsciously you're refrained from
trading but
the reason you should take his queen
watch what happens when you take his
queen so you can go ahead and do that
yeah he has to take back with the rules
and do you see that it's it's calling on
e1
has lost the support of the rook on d4
so now if you attack that knight on e5
it's not going to be able to move very
well because you can potentially deliver
background checkmate now how can you
open up that pin from e8 to e1 moving
the bishop where
from e8 to e4 you have a rook on e8
and it's x-raying the rook on e1 could
you remember
yeah so you need to move your bishop
from e7 but where do you move it to
attack the knight
that'd be d6 being protected by pawn so
he can't break with the rook
right and now you see why it was a good
idea not to move that c pawn out early
on
yeah i guess that's another thing i need
to realize
moving those because now i just fixate
on just moving pawns and [ __ ] like that
right when it's not that great and
sometimes creating a threat is
just for the sake of creating a thread
just isn't that good
it's just you know a threat has to have
an additional benefit other than the
fact that it simply attacks a piece
because
okay what if he retreats it you know
who's benefited all right
now could you find another way to apply
pressure on that knight on e5 remember
the knight on e5 is immobilized
yeah so i had a cool idea that i think
later ended up kind of
playing knight to g4 bishop cuts off the
background okay sorry to interrupt you
do it
absolutely do it now he's got a defense
here which
is not a 980 level defense but he's he's
been playing well above his rating
amazing knight g4
okay sorry did i just praise you sir can
i strike that from the record so nobody
in your chat will have heard that
i like i like it like when you say nice
things about me makes me feel good good
to know that way
i'll make sure not to do that ever again
okay so he's gotta find a defense here
he's either either he gets checkmated or
he loses that knight on e5 he does have
one defensive move
so let's see if he finds it i'm going to
keep mom about it in case
he's watching a certain stream dorcas
uprising oh dork uproar
darkest prizing
yeah there's a couple people in my
stream whose names i was misread like i
pronounced the first three letters and
then the last two
when like the first two and then the
last three make a lot more sense some of
them are just [ __ ] tough man
you just don't know what they're going
for okay you found it
wow yeah because that protects the e1
right there so i can't just go in
but believe it or not you have another
move that
you see that knight on d3 is guarding e1
so
you can move your piece out onto a
square that's defended by that knight on
d3
but because that knight can't move it's
actually a really good move
if you know what i'm saying
you could attack another one of his
exposed pieces in the center
i guess i'm not really seeing it so i
understand the knight can't move because
if he does
it's a back rank checkmate so that
knight is absolutely held down right
there right you could attack
i don't see the rook on d4 is the piece
you can attack
with one of your pieces oh because yeah
because you can't take it back with the
knight so yeah i just bring the bishop
over here to c5
exactly and notice how you're skewering
that rook on d4 the pawn on f2 that pawn
on f2 guess what
it's also defended by the knight and
once again well he takes
okay you can just take back and he still
can't take your bishop
he's got to move his rook out and then
you have a real five head move
once again exploiting the fact that his
knight cannot move from d3
okay this guy is definitely not 980 but
you're still playing well
any ideas so would i
obviously the first thing i looked at
was taking that pawn on f2 with the
bishop
he has to take with them then he gets
checkmated if he takes to the knight
yeah so obviously you can't take with
the knight exactly but you can just move
the king but then you've won the pawn
true well and the bishop's still
defended by the points yeah and that's
one of your issues sometimes you go
over you know you throw away moves where
you just
just went upon looking for something
more but here you don't have anything
more so
yeah you just got to do it and after he
moves his king to f1
then he's attacking your bishop so
you're gonna have to drop your bishop
back
well let's see if he first of all if he
even finds that move
maybe he'll get attracted by knight
takes bishop because technically you've
removed one of the pawns
that you know hem in the king but now
the knight takes its place okay he finds
it
so now just dropping the bishop all the
way back to b6 yeah protected
by pawn bingo and look for a different
attack
right you've got pieces all trained on
his king so despite the fact that the
queens are off the board
his king is not actually out of the
woods
and you see that bishop on f4
okay well he's just made a huge blunder
what square has he now relinquished and
this is a type of training that you've
done for
ages
black to play and win
don't tell me you need more fork
training no
i'm looking for a fork but i don't see
it because that night
still protects the fork that i'm looking
at what fork are you looking at
well the one i was looking at attacks
the
oh never mind that's just not even going
to work i see it's just this one right
here i was looking too low
yep knight e3 check yeah i i looked i
like a [ __ ] idiot i looked at e5
thinking night forks tonight that's
that's a fantastic idea so because i was
still under the impression the knight
couldn't move because it would be a
checkmate
right right that makes sense so now you
have a minute 46 and you're up a rook
let's see where he goes because okay now
he allowed checkmate in one
yes this is just going right back there
with the brokenness checkmate yep very
nice
very nice game um and especially
kind of capped by that move knight g4
definitely he he played well above his
rating you know i would say 12 1300
strength
but you know all of these moves you
found knight you four
um and and i think this game speaks to a
lot of things that you struggle with so
it's a nice segue into some of the work
that we're gonna be doing today
yeah being hesitant to take the queen i
think was the big thing there right
because you feel like uh it's an end
game somehow that's a concession but
in reality there are going to be
situations when you just need to bite
the bullet
and take the queen you cannot avoid a
queen trade every single game
if that makes sense makes sense to me
yeah buddy
all right so let's jump into some
training positions
of various kinds but they're all going
to be united by the fact that you
basically just need to find
maintenance positional moves good
squares for your pieces
trades you need to go for trades you
need to find a plan
you're going to struggle with this
initially i mean it's going to be
annoying but i think you're going to
come out a lot stronger
all right yeah it sounds good to me man
fantastic
all right so let me invite you to an
announce board
just invited
all right fantastic i'm gonna have to do
this
very specific way because it doesn't you
don't see it if i paste the position so
let me know in a second
if you see a new game pop up on the
screen
let's see uh this is the game we just
had
oh god here we go this again um
okay close out of that board i know what
i have to do
i hate this i wonder if
by the year 2030 this will be fixed
i think so i have high hopes for the
programmers yeah i mean this
this seems like a monumental task like
building a self-driving car
i wonder if by the time this analysis
board will be fixed like the first
self-driving car
will have been fully authorized to roam
the roads
are you afraid of that because i
absolutely am i am i
i don't think i would hit the roads if i
knew half of the cars will
we're self-driving cars yeah i mean i
know the technology's there like i have
no
doubt in the tech i just worry about
like [ __ ] hackers or something
just like taking control of your car and
crashing that [ __ ] into a wall or
something
or taking control of another car and
crashing it into yours
that'd be pretty [ __ ] tough they'd
have to like follow you
around in another car before hacking it
that's true
well i would never i would i'll put it
this way i would never sit in the back
of a car that does not have a driver
like i don't see myself ever getting
behind that or worse an airplane that
isn't of a pilot i've heard of that that
terrified the [ __ ] out of me
oh absolutely i would i want to shoot
terrifying i mean that i mean i don't
like flying as it is
much less of that a pilot okay so let me
see since this isn't working you're
still seeing
the final position of that game
let me try to paste in a specific
position hopefully this will work
and if not i'll manually input the moves
um
okay let's see if you see the position
changing
i'm looking at your stream
um it appears
nothing you know i'm making executing
moves
but i guess alexandra brought up
something about having chat disabled
sometimes
[ __ ] things how do i turn that on maybe
that's the problem we're experiencing
um chat disabled oh yeah it's probably
in your setting so click on that gear at
the top
um and that let me see i'm i'm looking
on my own
window let's see did it disable alerts
that's not alerts
yeah um alerts it's under alerts there
should be game chat
uh friends only okay so try everybody
and
yeah now i get i guess close out of that
board and let me try again
and one second you should be getting an
invite
in a moment yeah and if not i will just
manually input the moves
okay invited
okay uh i see something different here
now let me see
perfect oh no it so the right position
flickered and then the wrong position
took over
oh my goodness like it was briefly
yeah this is a game i played against
alexandra earlier that's so weird it was
briefly the right position and then it
was the wrong position
so anybody oh god chess.com is hearing
from me after this
i see you moving things let me see i'm
looking at your stream simultaneously so
it's moving at what it's doing is it's
moving pieces
on one game and on my screen it's moving
pieces on another game i'm sorry to drag
you through this
it's not your fault man you didn't
program it [ __ ]
hate this kind of incompetence but it is
what it is i'm sure oh they're
perfect you see it good amazing this is
it
believe it or not this is it uh so this
position occurred and i'll be showing
you examples from my games
not because i'm such a genius but
because you know that's just the
material that i have at my disposal
and your first task is going to be a
relatively straightforward one it's
going to be a task of finding
good squares for your pieces that's all
you're going to have to do you're
playing white here
uh i was playing white this is from a
tournament in denmark 2015.
um i was playing a guy by the imposing
name of fleming skilldogger yeah again
you only get these kinds of people in
chess that's [ __ ] that's all right
very intimidating player but i i was
outraging him by 700 points
and it's white to move here now i'm not
gonna
give you any hints i want you to try to
find the best move here
and the one hit i will give you is that
the best move simply takes a piece
and puts it on a really sexy square
okay that's so the first thing the first
thing i look at in a position
like this is what you taught me pieces
that aren't really doing anything and
right now that
knight on f3 doesn't serve too much of a
purpose
so what i was looking at was bringing
the knight to g5
it doesn't really threaten anything at
the moment because you can't take the
pawns but it is a nice square
okay let's unpack that for a second
you're thinking in the general right
direction
but you're still slightly tainted by the
fact that all of the
quote-unquote pieces that do [ __ ] you
feel like
have to do something attacking and if
you go knight g5 you see my moves right
yeah
uh i go h6 okay and and
all that's happened is you just now you
have to bring your knight back
g5 is not an enduring what's called an
outpost an outpost is a square
that's a supported by a pawn and b
is square from which none of your
opponent's pawns can dislodge
that piece if that makes sense so you do
have an outpost here
deep in your opponent's position that
you can slam one of your pieces onto
and that constitutes the correct move
try to figure out what i'm talking about
here
anything coming to mind i'm just seeing
positions the queen can be in uh but
it's a night move
okay so it was a night move okay it is a
night move but you looked at the wrong
night
the second knight on e4 it has a very
sexy square it can jump onto
well it's not the same square i just had
the other one on right god for a bit
cut your nuts off you say that
so dropping it you can only drop it
backwards
no c3 so that's not it you have to just
take the knight
right no there's another square you're
missing an outpost it's so deep in
black's position
oh it's d it's d6 it is d6 oh
yeah okay look at that beautiful that's
good it's protected by that and you know
knight g5 what you wanted to play it it
pressured f7 and this
this knight also pressures up seven so
when you put pieces on good squares
they're inevitably gonna serve attacking
purposes
but they're not only gonna serve
attacking purposes
so in return my opponent plays the move
knight to f8
just digging further into his hole and
now same exact task
he's allowed one of my pieces to access
another brilliant square in the center
which square am i talking about i'm
pretty sure i see that one that's
bringing the other knight to e5 right
bingo and are you creating a threat are
you attacking anything
uh attacking that f7 pawn still because
now you have two attackers on that so
the king can't take it
uh trade queen for two nights but i
don't think that would be
optimal right right that's pretty [ __ ]
exactly so
already black is essentially lost my
opponent plays rook takes d6 he gives up
in exchange so a rook for a knight in a
pawn which is
a reasonable trade um and
does he create any pawn weaknesses in my
position now do i have any isolated
pawns as a result
yeah your d4 pawn isn't protected by any
pawns
so that's just kind of out there right
exactly so my next move
is exactly the kind of maintenance move
that you sometimes need to just make i
solidify my control over that weak
d4 pawn
you know again bringing out a piece
that's currently doing absolutely diddly
squat
yeah so is it bringing the a rook to a
d1 so i brought the other rook to d1
because i asked myself
what it you know the way you think about
which rook to put on a square that's a
little bit advanced but you want to look
at the other rook
and ask yourself is it going to find
employment given
one of the placements so i the reason i
played rook fd1
is because i saw a future where let's
say the c file is opened
i can bring my other rook to c1 and it's
going to be very harmoniously placed
together with the other rook
okay that makes sense and just a couple
more moves and then we'll move on to the
next position
what you'll see is that he plays knight
b to d7
i refrain from the trade i i still don't
like trades
just like you it's just that sometimes
you have to make them
and after queen c7 the last move i want
you to find
is a move that uses this c6 bond as a
hook my plan is to open up that c file
so that
the other rook is going to find a very
nice square on c1 but
how do you actually do that what
maneuver what breakthrough
do you want to prepare in order to make
that happen
pushing the pawn doesn't necessarily
guarantee it because he has e6 to take
back as well so you don't open up this
e-file with that
exactly and even if you do you do it
through a pawn sacrifice which is not
ideal
so it's it's got to be another avenue
that you take but you're looking at the
right
pawn on c6 that's the hook how do we
exploit the hook
we've done a lot of hook training and i
thought i was pretty good at finding
these but this one maybe the position's
throwing me off because yeah i just i
genuinely don't see it
because it's it's not an attack we've
talked about hooks in the context of an
attack so you're trained to look at that
the move is b4
so you bring this b pawn up to b5 now
the reason you might not be seeing it is
because you're saying well doesn't b5
blunder upon
but remember what i've said to you
before not every good thing in chess
takes exactly one move
how are you going to prepare the move b5
like once you've played b4 what are you
going to do on the next move
uh you're probably gonna bring over that
rook right where
we're gonna bring it to the uh the c
file so that way if he takes you're
taking queen
well no the knight blocks it but you're
right that's kind of what i do
um like let's say black plays an empty
move you go rook c1
in preparation for the b file for the c
file opening
but how are we actually going to play
going to make this b5 move happen
so that it doesn't also blunder upon
we need to use the only way that's
moving yeah
it's you just have to move the knight so
the queen can protect that and
uh take back even better you can you can
use another pawn
you bring the other pawn up oh okay okay
a4 and then b5
and this is a positional plan where your
plan is to open up
a file for your rook and you do it by
means of essentially three
separate moves you bring the rook to c1
in preparation for that file opening
and then you use your pawns to
orchestrate upon breakthrough
so the key here is number one look for
outposts for your knights
squares that are protected by pawns and
that are inaccessible to your opponent's
pawns usually deep within your
opponent's position
okay that's number one and number two
remember that hooks
are not only used in the context of
attacking the king and exposing the
king's position
they can be used for other reasons such
as opening a file for one of your rooks
or creating carving out an outpost you
know there's a million things that you
can do using pawn hooks and pawn
breakthroughs
not only king related
that makes sense to me all right so
uh so any questions about this position
or everything pretty much clear
no how did it finish though don't
blueball me how'd this end
yeah the blue ball bad bad uh it
actually was a pretty long game but let
me paste in the rest
now he didn't exactly go h6 and g6 this
guy was rated about 2 000
so he you know he knew what he was doing
let's see if i can get away with
actually copying in the whole game
god forbid i hope your computer doesn't
[ __ ] explode as a consequence
hey it's not my computer it's just.com
don't you dare don't you
dare bring me exactly how did i
my deepest apologies yeah of course it
did spazz out as usual
wow it literally that position you have
on your screen
has absolutely nothing to do with what i
just did okay back to square zero i'm
going to manually
put are you sure you want to see the
rest of this game it was another 30
moves
it's but it's fine since it seems to be
a hassle don't worry about it
yeah i'll i can send you that off stream
but it wasn't i'll tell you this it
wasn't anything that interesting i just
kind of outplayed
it um yeah and
chess.com is getting a a stern talking
to from me afterwards
okay so next position just pasted it in
let's see
i'm not even hoping anymore but let's
see if you see it you do wow
this is a new position this is a new
position um my opponent in this game was
actually a grandmaster and i was playing
black so flip the board so you're facing
black um
and this is a
cross between technique and converting
winning positions
and sort of recognizing the greatest
asset in your position
and then tactical creativity so training
a bunch of different things here now
when you look at this position from
black's perspective what jumps to minds
immediately
what uh close to promotion does black
have any extra material here
yeah uh well no black's actually down
right
yeah so it's plus two you're down
a rook or i'm looking at white like a
[ __ ] idiot
jesus characteristic behavior yeah black
is up a rook
black is up well a rook for a piece so
he's up in exchange
he's up the exchange um
okay so black is up the exchange and as
you pointed out correctly
um there's a pawn on e2 and it's almost
that promotion
so you need to start by identifying your
greatest asset once you have done that
you need to start looking for ways to
you know essentially
convert that asset into something
tangible so what does that look like
in the context of this position what
does it mean to promote the pawn what do
we have to do
to make that happen you gotta get the
queen off of e1
gotta get the queen off of e1 but
probably there's a move that's occurring
to you which is something like
sacrificing your own queen
he takes that queen and then you promote
and you haven't gained anything you've
just exchanged one queen for another
queen
not only that you've actually given up
your past pawn so you need to find a
different way
to crash through remembering that his
queen cannot leave
e1 because that's gonna allow you to
promote so black to move and try to find
such a method of doing that
it's essentially a two move combination
it's not particularly difficult but
yeah so what i what i keep looking at
here from this position is taking that
pawn on c3 and looking to get the rook
over there on c1
definitely a fantastic beginning
d takes c3 b takes c3 and now what's the
follow-up
now we're just taking that pawn with the
rook excellent rook takes c3 he can't
take on c3 because of promotion so what
he does instead is he takes the pawn
with the knight
and now the situation has transformed i
no longer have a past pawn
but in place of that spawn he now has a
knight that's pinned by one of the rooks
can you finish right off here
he resigned after the move rook takes c3
in reality but
well assuming he was playing you he
would have definitely taken the pawn on
e2 he would never
he would have never thought of resigning
would have never occurred to him
that's fair all right um
now when you say finish off am i looking
for a checkmate or just winning pieces
or winning materials
even further that's why i showed this
position there's there isn't any
checkmates here his king is still
quote-unquote safe
so you need to identify his weakest
piece that's easy to do
and then find ways to attack it yeah
so the first attack is the obvious one
which is bringing the rook to c2 to put
more pressure on the pin
knight are you threatening to capture
the knight now
well yeah now we have two rooks on it
you absolutely are threatening to after
the night he's got only one possibility
rook to f2
now we need to find another way to put
pressure on that knight
and there is just such a move yeah it's
bringing the queen over to e3 right
because now that rook's not protecting
that
excellent he's got only one defense king
f1 what often happens
this is what you have to watch for if
your opponent has quote unquote
succeeded in his defensive test that
probably means he's left
other [ __ ] open for the taking and you
need to be
incredibly flexible in how you approach
the position there's one
grandmaster author who calls this
playing in pencil rather than playing in
pen
like you might have failed on the task
of winning the night but you've
succeeded in the overall task of winning
the game so what comes to mind here
first thing i looked at is moving the
king relinquishes the defensive h3 pawn
which also is a check
excellent let's take that [ __ ] if he
plays rook to g2
he self pins himself and what move is
now possible
now we're taking the knight excellent
and we're winning everything so he's got
to go kg1
keep taking stuff yes and now we just
take the next pawn at g4 which is
another check
exactly he goes king f1 unfortunately
we've run out of stuff to
immediately take so the question then
becomes
what kind of plan do we orchestrate now
in order to win the game
so i think uh this is an
area i struggle with so we have a whole
lot of pressure here there's a lot going
on
is it now we just look to maybe promote
since we're up on ponds over here maybe
we just look to push a pawn past and
like
a file b file in one of these two pawns
absolutely possible and the best way to
do that would actually be to take
everything on e2 you quote you
technically give up an exchange doing so
but you get into a pawn end game where
you're up two pawns which is completely
winning and then you would just
basically promote
but i wouldn't recommend that because
there's a much safer way
and faster way of converting which is
actually not promoting but
basically going for checkmate and in
order to go for checkmate
what i'm seeing is a position where this
rook on e8 lands on h1
he's completely tied up remember that so
you're not in a hurry
okay it's not like you need to do
anything immediately that's what you
need to beat into your own head
okay and
you need to find a maneuver whereby this
rook from e8 lands on h1
do you see such a maneuver uh
well what i see is pushing pawn on f7
f6 bring king out and then slide rook to
h8
that's there's a three move
there's a three move maneuver [ __ ]
my bad i i just oh wait i switched
positions
um i i actually nothing changed on my
board if you made me move
i'm i'm back okay i'm listening yeah so
then the other one is just bringing the
rook to e3 and then
h3 bingo okay and
remember i shared the three move role
with you that doesn't apply
here because this position is in
freaking ruins so
here's the the great thing about going
for checkmate even if he attacks your
rook on c2
can you still go rook h3
yeah it'd still be mate right because
then uh yeah finish me off
i want you to make the moves okay so
then we lose rook but we have this
position we
deliver this check right
okay and then we take here and now now
this is where i cut your nuts off
wait why that doesn't work that's not
checkmate [ __ ]
i go kingy too oh god i gave you an
escape square jesus yeah
don't go anywhere as punishment for that
i want you to find the best move here
you have attack you have a liquidation
tactic which essentially transforms the
position
into a situation where you're up a rook
try to find it it uses
it uses the concept of a pin
um i mean the the only pin that really
works here is just bringing the h2 rook
up if you take you take and then you win
a queen well you have the right idea but
the wrong execution
you can sacrifice your queen in order to
clarify the situation on the second rank
and then you pick off his queen
but you gain a rook at the end of the
day
is that by starting it at e1 and then
taking that rook there
well you can take the rook immediately
he takes oh and then just deliver the
check and when the queen's delivering
the check so
you have a bit of resistance to tactics
that involve a queen sacrifice which is
totally fine
um but remember you can give your queen
up if if
you gain it back there's nothing wrong
with that but do you see how this works
the king has to move and you take the
queen
yeah and then you promote that's just a
classic yeah that's just a classic
sacrifice so
don't you know that's why you got to
keep solving tactics even when you feel
like you've progressed
it's very easy to regress if you don't
maintain that
now where is the mate here
it's it's going with the the rook
instead of the queen right
thank you sir and the queen so this is
another subtle
observations i made you got to be very
careful when you're going for mate that
you don't relinquish your control over
one square
you know by making a move it's very easy
to forget control over squares is
a very temporary thing it can easily
come and go
so you've got to watch all those squares
and make sure they're still under your
control
so in in summary when you have a
situation like this you're winning
you're up material
there's two fundamental approaches one
is simplification
followed usually by promotion or just
collecting all the pieces
but the other is to go for checkmate you
like to go for checkme but what you
sometimes miss
is that you're not immediately in a
hurry like if you look for immediate
checkmate here
you wouldn't find anything but if you
realize that you had one or two moves to
orchestrate some sort of maneuver
well you saw rookie 3 pretty quickly you
saw this idea pretty fast
so look for target squares for your
pieces try to get them there
but at the same time don't be blind to
what your opponent is doing he might
pose
hidden threats and you've got to be very
flexible in terms of changing your
strategy based on what your opponent is
doing
yeah that makes sense sorry for the you
know little sermon at the end but
i i think that this area is is is one
where you definitely struggle
okay so let's one moment let me choose
the next position
so let's let's do something on on the
same theme of
identifying your main asset and then
finding a sequence of moves to
transform that asset into something
tangible and it's actually going to be
the same exact asset
as the one we looked at in this game but
i want to give you practice with this
okay and then we're going to do some
more sort of
positional training but i want to hammer
this point home
it's white to move so flip the board
again so you're facing white
here i'm not going to give you any ends
it's simply white to play and win the
game with
the correct sequence of moves try to
find it
and you know you don't take take as long
as you need to to think about this
okay
yes it's i mean it start starts with the
promotion
take bishop and then i still have these
two pawns that i look to promote
um that's a that's a b-plus option uh
but that leads to some
messiness because he takes one of your
pawns and he has his own past puns
you identified the asset correctly which
is that you want to promote this pawn
but the purest way of promoting it would
be would be to get rid of that bishop on
d7 can you
distract it from its control over that
diagonal
so you know you're thinking in the right
direction here
but take this okay so you're talking
about like yeah yeah you're talking
about just bringing the bishop here to
threaten it
make it get off yep that's exactly what
i'm talking about
and black is only one move he's got to
move the bishop to g4 that's the only
available square on this diagonal
and now comes exactly the type of move
that
might not appeal to the eye but it's
actually incredibly strong
so maybe you see it at me i don't want
to disawait you from speaking your mind
here but
be careful
well it's obviously not a pawn move i
can't move either my other two pawn well
no
i could i could push this h pawn and
then you have no available squares on
this diagonal
that's exactly right h3 and here might
well let's say let's say i go king e7
does that
prevent you from doing what you want to
do here
no i still want to take that and then
promote right you take the bishop you
don't care about the fact that he takes
one of your pieces nobody gives a [ __ ]
about that because you promoted yep and
the game is over very nice
so this concept of identifying your
biggest asset
and asset can mean a million different
things it can mean your strongest peace
it can mean a weakness in your
opponent's position it can mean an
outpost
and making that happen making the
necessary trades
you know that can carry you very very
far in a position where
you otherwise don't really see what to
do
and one of the hardest things in chess
i would say in general is essentially
using
tactical methods to accomplish
positional things because that requires
obviously a grasp on tactics and an
ability to think
tactically but it also requires a grasp
on
on positional concepts that you know
otherwise
you know you might might fly over your
head entirely
so let's do one of those types of
positions which is
it's going to be difficult i'm going to
warn you it's also from one of my games
and it involves it involves the stopping
of your opponent's main idea
an idea can be something as simple as
finishing his development
okay so this is the position it's white
to move
try to break this down into two steps
what does black want to do how does
black want to complete his development
how do we stop black from completing his
development from
accomplishing his main idea and that way
you're going to find the move
this is called prophylaxis i actually
dropped that word today against
alexandria
sorry careful you're going to make me
you know i i'm on stream charlie
you get a cream on the camera yeah yeah
you watch out okay don't don't talk to
me like that
was she impressed she was she said
you're definitely getting trained by
daniel that's a daniel [ __ ] right there
we have prophylaxis
it's it's one of my favorite topics uh
to teach in general even to like very
very high rated students i
i'm a believer in the importance of
prophylaxis
so now since you said development could
be something or
idea could be as simple as development
the first thing i'm looking at is that
bishop hasn't developed yet and it's
locked in with pawns
so what i see is getting the bishop to
attack on kingside by pushing out that b
pawn to b5 and the move i see to stop
that is just pushing the a pawn to a4
protected by knight and cuts that off
because then you also have the knight
and the queen protecting for an attack
okay so that you're thinking in a very
good direction
one catch he doesn't actually want to
push his pawn out to b5 because
you didn't take inventory of all of your
pieces this bishop is skewering that
punch so
you're right that he wants to develop
this bishop on c8
but he doesn't want to develop into b7
where does he want to develop it
and how does he get it there he's
i mean for right now to develop he just
wants to get it to d7 then right so by
pushing out that pawn
too
hey does he want that pawn in the center
of the board there at d5 exactly that's
where he wants it
because that claims the center remember
black is up upon here so
you know he wants to play d5 and then he
wants to develop his bishop and he'll be
totally fine
stopping that threat takes a little bit
of imagination but i think you can find
the move
take your time there's no i mean this is
a it's a creative
approach to stopping this threat because
what you're looking at is
you're assuming that d5 is a bygone
conclusion and you're trying to find
ways can i control that square with my
pawns i don't have any pawns to control
it with [ __ ] i can't stop it but
there's an alternative method to
stopping such threats which is to
physically
you know sit on that yeah occupy
one of the squares that it crosses
so are we looking okay the only square
you can occupy that stops it from even
getting there is
d6 that's the tile we need to get to but
it's protected by bishop right so do we
need to come up with something to get
the bishop off to keep that pawn locked
in
you're tunnel visioning you're looking
at that bishop on e7 but you're not
looking at all of your pieces
that are controlling that square on d6
look at the whole board how many how
many controls how many attacks do you
have on that square on d6
we have the rook attacking it and we
have the bishop on it
so the fact that his bishop is
controlling it does that stop you from
going bishop d6
no but i guess my hesitation there is
having the rook that deep
that's a great thing his because you're
rook how can this rook be supported if
he tries to play a move like queen c7
how can this rook now be supported
well do we just develop we bring the
next rook over to d1 to stack the rooks
that's exactly what we do and this rook
is occupying i wouldn't really say an
outpost because it's not protected by a
pawn
but look at what you've done to his
position he cannot bring this bishop out
he's paralyzed
in this rook it's not easy to attack it
any further he can't
get to it with his knight if he tries to
intercept it
by playing knight d5 here you have a
little tactical move
find it
here you have a oh yeah we just we just
yeah we just take the knight
you can't take it back with the pawn or
else that's a discovery check right
that's exactly right we take it with a
rook
could we also take it with a knight yeah
so
oh because no he doesn't have to take
now we just lose the rook right so it
has to be the rook but think
think further yeah actually you could
take with the knight because here you
have another really cool move
using the fact that you put the second
rook on d1
thank you fatal life for the sub well
first thing i looked at was the fork at
c7 but it's still protected by queen so
that doesn't work i have nothing to take
queen back with
the x-ray relationship between the rook
and black screen is what you need to be
looking at here
yeah i just don't really know how to
free it
so the ideal movie you're looking for is
a night move that's also
check because then black has to attend
to that check and then you win the queen
with your rook
oh we i delivered the check on the other
side i was only looking at a single
check so it's the f6 check
it's the f6 check exactly so the key
here is is when one check doesn't work
you don't
you don't dismiss the category no more
checks you just look at the other side
of the board knight f6 takes
take the queen queen for a rook and
you're winning okay
that's cool this concept of asking what
your opponent wants to do and then
stopping it
you've applied that before but sometimes
you need to apply that in a large scale
um you know sometimes you can apply it
to ideas that don't seem that scary like
your opponent wants to complete his
development
with a certain desirable developing move
and you bring that square under control
or you literally
stop it by playing a move such as bishop
d6 blockading
the pawn on d7 that's called a blockade
yeah i was just gonna ask now let's say
he doesn't take that bishop uh do we
just hold that down then because we
don't want to take the bishop right
because then he's still completing
development and we can't really stop it
there right
right potentially we might want to take
the bishop because it brings his king
out into the center but i agree we
wouldn't
probably we wouldn't want to do it we
would just keep making general improving
moves such as rook fe1
we might expand on the queen side of b4
a move that you noticed
um and this knight on c3
um do you see a potentially desirable
central it's a square that it can reach
through
a two move maneuver and it's a very nice
meaty kind of square
this is the kind of maneuver you might
struggle with potentially
yeah so it obviously can't start with
going to e4 because it's protected by
night they just take the night
exchange let me preface this i'm talking
hypothetically because
right now the maneuver i have in mind
one of the squares is protected by
black's queen
so let's say the queen were dislodged
and sitting on d8 that would make it
easy for you
easier for you assume the black queen
was on d8 right now
in fact put it there now you can think
of this maneuver
i have the power in my hands the [ __ ]
okay
okay so uh i think the square that we're
looking to get the knight is it to the
c5 square because the c5 square has okay
so bringing your knight to the side of
the board is not that bad if you're
going for somewhere good you know you're
going to c5 you're attacking b7
and this is all falls under the category
of general pressure
sometimes it's like do you create a
specific threat not always sometimes
you're just improving the position of
your pieces
and you got to be okay with the fact
that you know the
the good stuff might come a little bit
later and that dovetails back into the
main reason i'm showing you all this not
all moves
have as their intention the delivery of
checkmate or the winning of a queen
some moves just improve your position
from a general perspective
makes sense to me okay there's other
times and you know we might do this one
more
one more position then transition to
openings because i'm sensitive that a
lot of these positions can get
challenging and kind of dreary
so i apologize for that good good
necessary work i think the position i'm
gonna paste in
right now involves the formulation of a
plan
that might not have the signature of
being
particularly imposing but it actually is
so it's a wolf in sheep's clothing and a
lot of these moves
are ones that you struggle with so you
see this position it's white to move
um it's a game that i played in 2012 in
holland
as you can tell chess has taken me all
over the world snowy snowy holland
december
that's wonderful i think i remember
slipping on the snow before this game so
i was particularly angry
and my opponent was the recipient of my
wrath so
what's going on here from a general
perspective who's better and why like
materially
speaking which is not a trivial question
by the way but
what can you tell me uh so right now
white is up
that is correct what is
well so white's lost a rook but in
exchange got an extra piece
so white's up one pawn i believe right
he's up so he's up upon
just looking at pawn well blackwood
what's going on it's seven pawns versus
seven pawns so pawn
count is equal but two pieces what you
say is two pieces for a rook
oh yeah yeah okay so they went with the
bishop and
knight for the rook right which is
advantageous because the wreck is
technically you're right
rook is five points and and bishop and
knight are three points each
so technically what is up a point but
let's transition the discussion to the
realm of
what's going on specifically here whose
king is better placed um
what ideas immediately jump to mind
so right now black's king has a lot of
attackers
eyeing down on it white's king is still
kind of safe in that regard
there's no like threat of back rank or
anything from the queen sliding to d1
because we still have plenty of escape
squares
rooks also there uh what jumped to mind
immediately was looking for an attack on
that g6 pawn because it can't get taken
by the h7 pawn anymore thanks to the
queen being there
and we can have two attackers on it by
bringing the knight to h4
and look maybe look an idea this way so
you're biting on granite here because
this pawn is actually black's
most well defended pawn because it's
defended by two other pawns
so are you oh because taking oh god
sorry sorry yeah because
you thought this pawn was pinned or
something yeah i thought i thought the
pawn was pinned i wasn't paying enough
attention i guess yeah
no it's okay so the pawn that you need
to be looking at is upon that if it's
captured with the right piece
it's going to be checkmate so you're
right in looking for pawns but which
pawn is the one that you really want to
try to attack
yeah so it's going to want to attack the
h7
the problem is there doesn't seem to be
an easy way
to put more pressure on that bond and
yet there is a plan that allows you to
quickly and efficiently
attack that one is it it's just bringing
the king to g2
sliding rook to h1 yeah that's exactly
right black has only one defense
and that defense allows basically a
devastating move
my opponent plays the move f5
okay you're just on post on now which
pawn do you on passant with and why
and this is oh actually wait sorry he
plays b3 which is
useless rook h1 f5 both
odd poissons work but i want you to
choose
one of them and explain to me why you
want passant with that pawn
so the one that i immediately thought
was the right one to on passant with was
the
g pawn and the reason why is because
just in my head freeing up that g file
made more sense to me given our position
and keeping that pawn locked on e6
okay but when you say freeing up the g
file are you going to put something
whoops are you going to put something on
that g file
no but i guess just the option of it
made sense to me
so the way that you do need to think
about this is you have two ampersands
and each of them
vacates a square for one of your pieces
that's currently not doing any attacking
which piece is currently not really
doing any attacking
i see so it's the knight you take with
the e pawn to bring the knight up voice
correct that's exactly what i did but g
takes f6 is also good because which
square does this guarantee for the
knight
this now gives the knight g5 bingo so
both moves would be acceptable
that's another thing you have to
consciously do when you're entering into
a trade
or you're pushing up a pawn you need to
ask yourself two questions what
weaknesses does that pawn move create
as i suggested you do in your warm-up
game where you could have pushed that
seat pawn up and that would have
weakened
another pawn but another thing you could
do is push upon up
your opponent pushes the pawn up and you
immediately ask yourself what squares
does that leave open for my pieces to
access what squares does it weaken
and by asking yourself that question you
can then come up with incredibly strong
maneuvers
i.e getting your pieces to those squares
so what happens is b takes a2
i put the knight on e5 and here my
opponent blundered checkmate in one he
played queen d4 kind of just resigning
the game
but let's imagine that he would have
played queen to c7
this is an area that you really struggle
with white is on the doorstep of
delivering checkmate
but how do you actually crash through
it's clear that something needs to be
sacrificed here something needs to be
thrown at black's king but
what is it and how do you do it you
throw the bishop at the g6
part no so if he takes on g6 where's the
mate
then i just bring it right down to h8
nicely done and if you know
but yeah it is good yeah because of the
knights protecting f7 yeah you begin to
wonder what genius thought of putting in
the knight on e5
um and if he takes on e5 if he takes the
knight on e5
then we just deliver the check made at
h7 yeah or g7 doesn't matter
exactly so you see that attacking
is not just a matter of making the most
imposing moves it's a matter of making
the
thoughtful moves and some of them can be
a little bit slow again and again and
again it's okay for stuff to take
two three moves as long as at the end of
that you deliver a nice punch
and sometimes you're just not in a hurry
sometimes your opponent
as in this position just doesn't have
any sufficient counter play to stir
things up in that span of time
[Music]
you